s'il ya bien un truc qu'on peut lire
chez sony c'est qu'ils savent vraiment
mais vraiment bien bossé l'audio ici on
a un truc tu es toujours qui vient à
peine d'arriver cwf billy 104 une
nouvelle forme nouvelle boîte mais
toujours autant les mêmes exigences au
niveau de dos et ça c'est vachement bien
[Musique]
à sony sony sony
moi j'ai testé pendant très très
longtemps les double dash qui me dis que
ce n 3 et double h moules xm 4 on parle
bien du casque ici mais j'ai pas eu les
wfx m3 ici par contre j'ai très heureux
de pouvoir vous présenter tout de suite
les matins mais d'à peine d'être
annoncées les wf 1000 x n 4 c'est
tellement compliqué les noms qui chez
vous s'occupe de trouver le nom des
produits qui est l'idée de se dire tiens
on va les appeler les z q herbert 354
qui pourquoi donc aujourd'hui on se
parle de ce produit là on se parle de ce
tout nouveau produit signé sony qui
déchire sa mère parce que vraiment chez
sony ils savent fabriquer de l'audio met
merveilleusement bien
c'est un produit qui est super
intéressant qui est super cool qui coûte
quand même 280 euros
voilà on se calme un petit peu ce pas
forcément très pour tout le monde mais
ce produit là à 280 euros si vous pouvez
vous le permettre si vous avez envie et
si vous voulez vraiment une eau
d'excellente qualité avec surtout une
réduction de bruit qui déchire et bien
vous allez voir que au final ces 280
euros ça vaut le coup des mecs là dedans
avant de parler du produit en tout cas
super intéressant à voir ici c'est le
packaging alors ya un vrai changement
déjà en voie au niveau de la forme au
niveau du produit forcément le packaging
va changer lui également ce que je vais
trouver moi ici super intéressant c'est
qu'on est sur des matériaux complètement
recyclable
donc là on est vraiment sur un truc
intéressant on est sur du carton déjà eu
un vrai parti pris de la partenaire à
vous me direz ça fait pas le produit en
tout cas ça montre la direction dans
laquelle veut partir ce ni recyclés
recyclables
on fait attention donc ça c'est bien
alors à l'intérieur et je vous le montre
qu'à vous avez de la doc on s'en fiche
un petit peu ce qui m'intéresse surtout
ce sont les différentes tailles
d'embouts alors je dirais que c'est un
peu un grand classique
vous avez du small vous avez du médium
qui sont directement posée celui-là vous
avez du large est en dessous ici vous
avez votre petit câble parlons
maintenant des écouteurs en eux mêmes
alors déjà comme on le voit ici il ya un
vrai changement au niveau de la forme
par rapport à ce qu'on avait sous clé wf
1000x m3 à la génération précédente
ici on est sur des buzz on est sur des
petits bugs et ça c'est un truc est
vraiment différent équipe au cou est
super intéressant pourquoi parce que les
wf mg 3 même s'il était très bien et
marché très très bien et bien et est
très grand ici par contre on vient dans
la la taille du buzz un petit peu plus
standard avec ce côté là voyez qui est
toujours très très
premium on a ce côté métal un peu cuivre
et ce côté blanc là qu'on peut retrouver
sur leur casque on est vraiment dans
l'environnement sony ça ça marche super
super bien et puis surtout une
différence qu'on a cette année qu'on
n'avait pas l'année dernière vous êtes
ici sur des embouts en polyuréthane
alors les jambes au polyuréthane ils ont
un intérêt c'est qu'ils viennent
complètement épouser la forme de votre
oreille lorsque vous les insérer et
après voyez ils reviennent prendre leur
forme initiale ce qui fait que lorsque
vous les mettez dans vos oreilles pour
dire vraiment s'aplatir on les entend
reprendre leur forme initiale
il faut qu'ils sont calés bouge plus le
vrai intérêt c'est l'isolation passive
ils viennent complètement obstruée votre
canal auditif adapté totalement à la
forme de vos oreilles donc il ya déjà
vos boucher les oreilles pour éviter que
le son extérieur dû rentrer et pour
optimiser l'expérience de réduction de
bruit active le reste après très simple
vous avez votre petit boîtier dans
lequel vous avez vos écouteurs petite
led
ici quand sévère c'est que ces charges
et vous venir recharger ici en usb avec
le câble qui fondit interview la
première chose qui va nous intéresser
ici c'est le confort ce que vous venez
les mettre dans vos oreilles alors les
bugs à ce mec comme ça
prenez vous mettez vous tournez la vous
entendrez bluetooth connected alors moi
j'ai laissé en anglais mais sinon vous
pouvez mettre en français batterie folie
chat
oui mon accent extraordinaire et la même
chose pour l'autre vous prenez garde et
vous mettez vous tournez batterie folie
de charges alors comme on dit tendu
trouvailles en laisse et du bluetooth et
1.2 est bien c'est que chacun va
communiquer indépendamment avec votre
smartphone
le vrai gros bénéfices qu'on va voir ici
c'est que la tenue est super bonne alors
on peut bouger un peu pogoter on peut
danser alors ici je peux ne serait pas
un loyer je suis dans mon studio ça
serait un peu débile mais vous pouvez
bouger
donc ça c'est intéressant si par contre
vous voulez aller faire une course en
extérieur faire un run phare du vélo
parce que vous voulez la tenue elle est
vraiment mais vraiment vraiment
excellente
en plus de ça si vous faites du sport
ils sont certifiés ipx4 résistant à la
sueur résistant à la transpiration xive
ou dégouliner pas de souci là-dessus et
également la pluie quand on se parle
casse quand on se parle musique on se
parle avant tout de qualité ben oui
qualité audio c'est ce qu'on veut en
premier parce qu'avoir effectivement un
truc et bien qu'il tenait dans l'oreille
c'est vachement bien mais si la musique
est pas top 6 le niveau est pas top et
blonde et rapidement vers des alors ici
rapidement embêter devrait obtenir
rapidement embêté ça serait lui on est
rapidement embêté ça fait le taf mais
grave ça fait le taff énormément ça
marche tellement bien la qualité est
vraiment là c'est un savoir faire de
sony qui est maîtrisée assure maîtriser
savez sony sont énormes frais avait au
cinéma / de la production vous les avez
dans votre téléviseur vous avez dans vos
oreilles faisait même temps votre
smartphone vous les avez partout sony ce
qui fait que ça là ce petit buzz on peut
l'appeler comme on veut eh bien ça
marche du feu de dieu que tout est super
intéressant ici c'est que vous avez un
nouveau diaphragme de 6 mm alors si mm
ça paraît pas énorme c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup qui mettent
des diaphragmes un peu plus gros pour
augmenter la qualité audio et der garde
et qui si sony avec du 6 mm il envoie du
pâté envoie du steak il met quand même
je peux dire beaucoup de monde par terre
et à genoux mais franchement oui
franchement on va retrouver des baux
grave bien rond qui ronronne qu'on peut
venir complètement optimisé via l'app
mais ça c'est autre chose et tout le
monde en quelques instants une fois de
plus vous avez des aigus qui sont
extrêmement précis tout le reste du
spectre que ce soit médium médium grave
médiums aigus
c'est top alors je sais que c'est très
compliqué de se rendre compte comme ça
au travers d'une vidéo parce que vous ne
pouvez pas vous les écoutez
mais je puis vous assurer que la qualité
est au rendez vous je puis vous assurer
que le 2e marche super bien vous assurer
qu'on prend un plaisir dingue à venir
les utiliser moi j'aime vraiment
vraiment vraiment beaucoup et le truc
qui marche super bien en plus il est
complètement sublimer ici c'est la
réduction de bruit active on se dirait
qu'avec des bugs comme ça qu'avec des
petits écouteurs comme ça eh bien on va
pas nécessairement avoir la meilleure
réduction bruyant c'est vraiment ici un
travail qui est fait en duo avec la
réduction de bruit passive qui vient
très très bien vous isolez comme je vous
le disais
grâce à cette mousses en polyuréthane
ont plus de ça vous avez différents
micros qui vont venir travailler pour
capter le son ambiant et pour venir
l'annuler à l'intérieur faire un système
dehors phase le to qui vous donne une
vraie belle expérience au niveau de la
réduction de bruit
j'ai pris l'avion ça vous suppriment
vraiment le bruit environnant
j'ai pris le train
[Musique]
je suis pris vraiment le bruit
environnant je me suis mis dans des
environnements bruyants les cachant pas
ce que c'était subaru fallait pas qu'on
les voit et bien je puis vous assurer
que le rendu est là et ça c'est vraiment
vraiment cool donc ça j'aime beaucoup
c'est vraiment plus que j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup ici vous êtes sûre du
24 bits certifié à erez audio wireless
vous avez du hell d'ac et on nous
annonce des fréquences qui parle de 20h
jusqu'à 40 milliards alors chez sony il
ya plein de techno vous avez le ds e
extrême c-19 skelling au niveau du son
qui va venir augmenter la qualité de
votre source audio quelle qu'elle soit
c'est par exemple vous écouter sur une
source qui n'est pas dingue dingue on
est bien venir augmenter la qualité
saulnier nous allons st gall
performances de l'ordre de 40% par
rapport aux wf melixon 3 on se pare donc
de la génération d'avant
ici en plus ont un tout nouveau
processeur c'est le processeur v1
vous avez toujours trois micros deux
micros extérieur un micro intérieure et
une fonctionnalité qui avait été
présenté que le wsj dixon c'est ce qui
s'appelle le speak to chat le speak to
chat c'est lorsque vous avez vos
écouteurs et vous écoutez de la musique
vous vous mettez à parler à quelqu'un
vous arriver je vois dans un endroit
pour me dire commander à boire ou à
manger et bien vous commencez à parler
la musique s'arrête vous avez l'ambiance
entre qui va venir à s'activer et qui
vous permettra de converser avec la très
facilement et lorsque vous repartez vous
arrêtez de parler ça s'arrête et ce à
partir moi je ne suis pas hypra fans de
ce système
non pas qu'il ne fonctionne pas je suis
pas ultra fan d'un point de vue social
arrivée parler à quelqu'un alors que
vous avez des buzz dans les oreilles
comme ça je trouve qu'il ya un côté un
peu un peu bizarre peut-être pour moi
alors je sais pas du tout ma bouche que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaires me
font pas ça complètement dingue dingue
mais bah c'est peut-être que moi
peut-être qu'elle est un endroit sur
terre où ça pose pas de problème
peut-être qu'en france sans pause
peut-être que chez vous ça en pause ou
pas dites le moi parce que je serais
vraiment curieux de savoir mais à côté
de ça l'ambiance mode qui vous permet de
restituer tout le son extérieur qui vous
l'envoie en fait qui vous l'injectent
directement au travers des micros et
bien s'arrache vachement bien on a
vraiment un secret très naturelle des
leçons de la pièce qui vraiment
restituer et je trouve que pour le coup
l'ambiance hand c'est vraiment un truc
qui marche super bien donc là dessus
très très beau travail une fois de plus
de la part de sony sony nous annonce ici
jusqu'à 24 heures de musique grâce à la
recharge avec votre boîtier et par
écouteurs vous passer de six heures sur
le marque 3 à 8 heures sur le mark iv et
vous monter jusqu'à 36 heures sans
réduction de bruit en plus ici prévient
de recharger sans fil c'est à dire que
si vous avez une base de rechargement
sans fil et bien au pla i les combats
cible qi qui arrache donc ça c'est bien
et en plus il est complètement
compatible avec la charge inversée donc
si vous avez un smartphone de sony
entrant très bien pourquoi pas et que
vous avez de l'argent versé vous
l'actionner vous le posez dessus vous
les recharger rapidement donc ça c'est
bien et si vous êtes un peu à combattre
y en cinq minutes de schaffhouse est
reparti pour une lecture profiter de sa
musique ça c'est vachement bien me direz
vous mais qu'en est il lorsque je veux
passer un coup de fil et batteux qui
marchent aussi vachement bien ici
lorsque vous voulez joindre votre
famille vos amis vous voulez passer un
coach si vous avez plein de techno qui
sont super intéressante vous avez
notamment un système de conduction
osseuse alors me direz vous qu'est ce
que la conduction osseuse en quoi ça va
venir me servirait à quoi ça va
m'intéresser lorsque j'ai passé un coup
de fil ça doit vous intéressez pas ce
que ça va reconnaître les mouvements de
votre mâchoire
lorsque je bouge comme ça voyez ça via
les reconnaître ça c'est donc que vous
êtes en train de parler et ça va venir
optimisé pour tous vos appels ça va
optimiser également grâce aux trois
micros que vous avez deux micros
extérieur et le micro intérieure et le
résultat pour vos appels est super bien
vous entendez très bien votre
interlocuteur la qualité est là bref
vous l'avez compris c'est un truc qui
marche super bien que ce soit pour
écouter de la musique pour regarder des
films des séries sur un ordinateur sur
un smartphone sur ce que vous voulez et
pour passer vos appels téléphoniques ce
petit truc là là c'est vraiment un super
bon produit en plus ici vous avez de la
connexion rapide sur android un peu
comme ce que vous avez sur ios vous
l'ouvrez et vous venez la période très
facilement ça marche aussi bien sur
android et vous avez également la swift
père sur windows dis donc ça c'est très
très cool et toute la partie des
contrôles et bien c'est exactement la
même chose que vous aviez sur le w1100
roi et après vous viviez tout piloté
depuis votre application ici et une fois
que vous êtes là vous avez accès à
beaucoup d'informations la première
c'est les informations de batterie que
vous allez voir ici alors nous connecter
cas donc vous avez qu'à un moment vous
avez les deux vous voyez ici le contrôle
adaptatif que vous pouvez venir
totalement paramétrer détecter les
actions à l'arrêt compagnie
apprentissage des endroits que vous
fréquentez enfin moi ya pas mal de
petites possibilités ça c'est un truc
que je vous ai déjà présenté sur le w h
music scene 4 ensuite vous avez la
partie sont ici j'ai le contrôle de son
ambiance sur la réduction de bruit
voyez je peux venir switcher son ambiant
ou alors ne rien mettre du tout et
ensuite venir choisir hostile sons
ambiants 1 combien je veux est ce que je
vais en gros sons ambiants qui pousse
énormément au jeu la majesté par exemple
la voyez là je me mets à à 20 heures
et là j'entends vraiment bien tout ce
qui se passe autour de moi de façon
complètement naturel concentration sur
les voies aussi prend les voix tout en
réduisant le bruit donc là ça vous
permet vraiment de vous concentrer
uniquement sur les voies et sur les
fréquences des voix et atténuer le reste
du son lecteur donc ça c'est vachement
le vous avez une réduction automatique
du bruit du vent vous avez ce qu'on
appelle le pictochat le parler putsch
était alors moi je n'ai pas activé parce
que c'est vraiment pas un truc que
j'aime bien vous voyez par exemple la up
je me mets je suis en train de parler ça
me met sur son ambiant et ensuite je
leur mets différents paramètres
détection de la voix automatique
concentration sur la voie temps jusqu'à
la fermeture du mode standard 15
secondes voient leur courte 5 secondes
ça veut dire que lorsque je fais ça
voyez je m'arrête 2 par année pendant 5
secondes et seniors switcher sur la
réduction briquet ensuite vous avez un
égaliseur ça c'est vraiment bien pour
moi c'est l'application la plus complète
à que je connaisse aujourd'hui ça marche
vraiment bien
vous avez plusieurs possibilités moi je
me suis mis sur personnaliser je te fais
mon petit et ku vous pouvez choisir
entre vifs enthousiaste calme
décontracté champ bref après faut
trouver celui qui vous correspond
personnellement ce que je vous conseille
c'est personnalisés moi j'ai poussé les
clients basse à fond j'ai entendu
beaucoup de base aujourd'hui vous
cliquez ici vous me réglez sur les
bandes de fréquences alors je n'aurai
pas normés mmm est ce que vous avez
largement suffisant 4 101 kg deux kilos
et demi 6 kg 3 16 kg et ensuite les
bassistes vous venez moduler voulait
monter ou pas ici vous avez choix
priorité à la qualité sonore haute va se
permet d'activer le hell d'ac ici ou un
connexion stable à moi ce que je
conseille c'est dépasser ici là vous
mettez ici vous avez lu et d'almeida que
vous l'avez uniquement sur android vous
n'avez pas sur un smartphone à ios parce
qu'ils ne sont pas compatibles d'akela
j'ai activé le ds e extrême pour le
screening audio et ensuite vous
choisissez si votre assistant vocal moi
j'ai mis goût de la saison mais vous
pouvez avoir amazon avec ça vous venez
ici paramétrique tout ce qui va être
tactile c'est vraiment super bien voyez
l'application elle est vraiment vraiment
vraiment très très bien pensée plage sur
le gauche je peux aller sur le droit et
je viens totalement ensuite paramétrer
ce dont j'ai besoin ce dont j'ai envie
directement ici voyage un petit menu
c'est vraiment vraiment génial c'est
hyper intuitif et très facile et pour
moi là dessus ce n'est ils sont juste
numéro 1 tout ce qu'ils peuvent vous
proposer réglage du fonctionnement
contrôles sont bien voyez c'est
complètement
c'est hallucinant l'arrière tout cas
super bien c'est déterminer les
oreillettes optimale vous venez cliquez
ici et vous faites test les conditions
port il vous envoie un peu de musique
qui vous demande de ne pas bouger pour
venir voir à l'adhérence des oreilles
regardez là par exemple il me dit
ajuster les conditions de port du casque
ou remplacer les oreillettes par
d'autres puis démarrer ensuite donc la
riche en train de parler il n'a pas trop
aimé et j'ai neuf fonctionne et est
qu'elle est géniale de sousse et
comparez toutes les tailles
donc là je vais venir toutes les mettre
les unes après les autres et lui me dira
quelle est la meilleure configuration
pour les oreilles lorsqu'il va faire ce
qu'il va mettre de la musique il va
venir analyser grâce aux différents
micros et indira maintien à gauche il
faut du s par exemple à droite il faut
du m donc ça je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment génial hyper intuitif et
l'application et la super loin
d'éteindre automatiquement le casque
s'interrompt en retirant le casque la
choisissez votre langue je laisse en
anglais vous pouvez mettre en france et
télécharger automatiquement les
logiciels pouvait venir réinitialiser
les réglages donc vous voyez qu'en
termes d'application on a un truc hyper
hyper complet qui marche super bien sony
travaille super super bien aussi bien au
niveau de son hardware au niveau de son
matériel qu'au niveau de la partie
software donc on a vraiment des
écouteurs qui sont juste voir juste
triste
rien à rajouter nouveau format nouveau
buzz compact application toujours autant
complète qualité audio qui déchire plein
d'options peut faire plein de choses
prenaient des films des séries passer un
coup de fil
voilà ça c'est une super réussite le
seul truc qui déconne un petit peu ici
c'est le donc toujours trop compliqué
chez sony sony s'il vous plaît arrêtez
avec les nôtres compliqué wf 1000 x n 4
j'aime faire le montage de la vidéo
c'est la dernière celle que je tourne
parce que j'avais oublié d'activer micro
donc ça marchait pas je te regarde et je
confonds pendant tout le temps entre le
double dames dixon 3000 x mkw mwh
je ne plante complètement voilà donc
c'est un peu la galère j'arrêtais
changer d nous ont appelés juste salle
et les jolies écouteurs de sony sony
aurait fait très bien et ça marche
parfaitement bien à vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez y en marre
commentaires comment vous les trouvez
cwf melix m4 bien est-ce qu'il vous
botte est ce que vous avez eu les wf mix
m3 est ce que vous avez w/h nixon trop
w/h mixette 4 et est ce que ça ça à 280
euros ça vous fait de l'oeil bleu marqué
en bas en commentaire quand on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler de ta vie de l'amour et moi je
vis avec ça mais j'adore ce gel
ce mur il est dans les yeux voilà voilà
des binômes ciao